well if it isn't the show that's a
vegan's worst nightmare beef is Netflix
and a 24's insane drama comedy that will
have you thinking twice about ever
honking your horn at a stranger in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
its ending the characters and getting to
the bottom of what the hell actually
happened so grab your Burger King
chicken sandwiches and make sure to like
And subscribe because here we go beef
follows two tragically flawed characters
there's Danny Cho a struggling
contractor who tries to kill himself
with carbon monoxide from hibachi grills
and Amy Nakai a lonely housewife who
Pleasures herself with her husband's
firearm so basically two mentally stable
individuals the beef the show is named
after occurs between these two
characters in episode 1 the two get into
a road rage incident which Spurs them on
a Path of Revenge with their beef
increasing to ever more dangerous levels
as their lives slowly implode around
them this leads us to the beginning of
the show's final episode Amy has lost
her husband custody of her daughter and
her business is likely gone too after
her employer was severed in half by a
panic room door Danny has ruined his
relationship with his brother Paul
accidentally burned down his parents
home he's been saving up for for years
and is wanted by the police for
kidnapping Amy's daughter their beef has
essentially destroyed both their laws
but as I'll point out later on this beef
will be ultimately what saves them just
like in episode 1 the final episode
begins with a case of road rage this
time on the dangerous winding Cliffs of
Southern California which sees both of
their vehicles plummeting over the edge
but what happens next is truly absurd
two crows talk to one another commenting
on the crash yes two crows talking to
each other the show up until this point
hasn't had any sort of magical realism
like this but this absurdity parallels
the absurdity of Amy and Danny's beef
it's weird silly and at times funny just
like their beef we also get this strange
artwork with the episode's title figures
of light in fact every episode features
a piece of art accompanied with the
episode's title which derive from
quotations from famous writers and
thinkers figures of light comes from
Carl Jung's alchemical studies and these
figures refer to the potential
transformation and spiritual growth that
exist within us some examples of these
archetypical figures he talks about
include the wise old man the nurturing
mother the Healer and only by
integrating these figures of light into
our psyche can we access our deepest
potential for growth and transformation
in this episode Amy and Danny tap into
these figures of light as they begin to
see each other for who they really are
rather than their Rage which is clouded
their judgment the colors emanating from
the ground represent the Skittles they
puke out of physical representation of
them letting go of their hate and
embracing each other for who they really
are the real Poison here is their hatred
in fact the two get to a point of
understanding each other so well that
there's a moment both characters switch
bodies Amy speaks from Danny's body and
vice versa it's not until Amy and Danny
eat the poisonous plant that the two
come to this Enlightenment but before we
get to that moment the two are still at
each other's throats
why did you make me do that even though
Dany pushes Amy off the cliff he still
thinks it was her fault stating why'd
you make me do that both characters
can't let go of their beef they can't
see how they themselves have contributed
to the problem in fact their choices in
the cosmic expanse of cause and effect
have led them to this very moment you're
born
my choices
and suddenly
you're here at any moment either of
these characters could have been the
bigger man and stopped the feud a
perfect example of this occurs here next
time someone honks at you maybe Let It
Go or maybe next time think twice before
you honk how about that but something
within them doesn't let them let go it's
only by letting go that both of them can
grow and become better people for it or
as young would say be transformed by
these figures of light after eating the
poisonous plant both characters face the
darkness of their past and it turns out
both of them share the same fear the
fear of being alone as a kid Amy's
parents never wanted her and as an adult
she's now lost her husband and daughter
Danny felt alone and the only thing he
could cling on to was his brother Paul
he even threw out his college
applications so he wouldn't leave him as
they delve deeper into their
hallucination the two come to see each
other for who they really are which is
physically represented by the two of
them switching bodies here Dany is in
Amy's body and sees her back tattoo on
his body it's a bit confusing but this
allows them to see just how lonely the
two really are
Danny and Amy needed their beef because
without it they'd never grow as
characters and become better people
Danny would have either killed himself
or continued to screw up his brother
Paul's life Amy would have continued to
bottle her emotions and secrets and
resent her family for it and likely pass
this on to her daughter June her biggest
fear is turning her daughter into what
her parents turned her into now you have
to pass that trauma down in episode 8
we're introduced to this weird looking
woman inspired by Viola Swamp from the
Miss Nelson book series she's the
manifestation of Amy's Secrets which
first appear when she finds out her
father is having an affair she kept this
secret hidden because as the mysterious
woman says I can't tell
secrets
how come because no one would love you
the finale allows Amy and Danny to
reveal those darkest parts of themselves
they haven't revealed to anyone Danny
tells Amy about his aborted suicide
attempts and how he almost stabbed
Paul's eye out as a child Amy tells
Danny that George and her daughter don't
feel like home to her that their love is
conditional and this idea of
unconditional love is something Amy has
yearned for her entire life and as I'll
argue at the end of the video it's
something she'll get from Danny and as
the two come to better understand each
other their Journey ends with a camera
zooming into the ground this is the same
image that was briefly shown for a few
seconds in episode 7. and it's here some
have argued that Amy and Danny have died
they have returned to the Earth from
which they came as aim even says at the
end of the episode
nothing less remember these guys
survived a horrific car crash lost lots
of blood had no water and ate an
extremely poisonous plant but I want to
hear what you thought about this did
they die here or does what happens next
actually happen the next morning Amy and
Danny make it back to civilization their
phones receive reception and even though
the messages coming in are extremely
negative such as Paul telling his
brother he's blocking him or finalizing
the child custody papers for Amy the two
seem happy just to be alive they make
their way into a tunnel where George
unexpectedly shows up and shoots Danny
although Dany is silhouetted here it's
likely George knew it was Danny and
given their history saw him as a threat
this leads us to the hospital where
Danny is hooked up to a ventilator by
his side is Amy she obviously cares for
him and has a flashback of the first
time they met in the parking lot of
Foresters the meeting that started their
beef in the first place we get this
interesting shot of Amy pausing for a
moment before deciding to give Dany the
finger this just goes to show that our
lives are a series of choices that lead
you to the present and these choices are
not necessarily predetermined rather the
result of our Free Will her choice to
give Dany the finger has led her here
not some predestined act episode 8 is
even titled the drama of original choice
which refers to a concept in philosophy
that the choices we make in life are not
determined solely by external factors
but rather our own desires values and
beliefs the final scene is also
accompanied by the Smashing Pumpkin song
mayonnaise whose lyrics reflect the
themes of a regret loss and
understanding in many ways it holds a
mirror to Amy and Danny's Journey Amy
gets up and crawls beside Dany embracing
him this isn't a romantic love nor is it
something platonic this is that
unconditional love that thing she's been
yearning for her entire life that thing
both of them have been yearning for They
Know Each Other's darkest Secrets fears
insecurities and yet still love each
other unconditionally and as this
happens it looks as though the day turns
into night fast forwarding and time
suggesting she's by his side the whole
way through but strangely the colors
start to change reflecting the same
colors from the Skittles these colors
represent Transcendence Amy and Danny
have gone through their darkness and
come out the other side as better people
their journey of hate has led them to
one of love but what did you think of
beef I want to hear all your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
crap